a small group of protesters gathered
outside the U.S embassy in Kiev
their message was clear
no war with Russia
but despite a week of frenzy diplomacy
there's no sign yet of a military climb
down
more U.S troops are being deployed to
Southeastern Poland bringing the total
to over 6 000.
the United States has also begun moving
its forces from Germany to Romania
around a thousand NATO troops are
expected to follow in the coming days
Denmark has also announced it is
enhancing its military preparedness
deploying fighter jets to the Baltic Sea
but NATO's reaction in response to the
more than 100 000 Russian troops amassed
near Ukraine's borders
are not viewed as a direct defense of
Ukraine
now in terms of numbers this is meant to
be a symbolic show of resolve that the
NATO is United and it will defend its
members if attacked for Ukraine we've
provided arms and training but we're not
providing any direct forces nobody is
further Consignments of British weapons
have arrived in Ukraine
Britain has said it only intends them to
be used in self-defense
speaking in Berlin on Wednesday German
Chancellor Ola Schultz said a dual
approach was needed
adding while all diplomatic channels
must be pursued allies must be prepared
to act if Russian forces cross these
borders and enter Ukraine
my first guest knows firsthand about the
realities on the ground in eastern
Ukraine from 2014 to 2018. Alexander
hoog was the principal deputy chief
monitor of the organization for security
and cooperation in Europe's special
monitoring mission to Ukraine Mr hook
joins me tonight from the Hague it's
good to have you on the program Mr Hogue
you know in the past few months we have
heard Non-Stop about the buildup of
Russian troops along the border with
Ukraine there has been less focus on the
ongoing conflict in the donbass region
of eastern Ukraine and I say ongoing
because the finding there it has not
really stopped has it
good evening thank you for for having me
indeed the reports of the oec special
monetary missions suggests that the
fighting in eastern Ukraine at that
almost 500 kilometer long contact lines
separating government from
non-government-controlled area continues
however the number of violations
recorded by that mission are now far
lower than at the beginning of the
conflict currently on a seven day
average between two to three hundred
measured with the last Peak just having
been before Christmas last year but
indeed There is almost everyday
violations recorded people still getting
injured and killed more damage to
infrastructure is being recorded and the
fighting forces on both sides are far
too close that a situation could evolve
that would then enable a ceasefire to
become sustainable well Mr hooker how
important is it in your opinion for
Ukraine to receive receive weapons from
the U.S and the UK for example when it
comes to dealing with the separatists in
eastern Ukraine
the Ukrainian forces have learned and
demonstrated over the years that they
are capable of defending the line that
they are now holding for quite a while
looking at this very long front line
stretching from the Asaf sea up north
then eastwards towards the border with
the Russian Federation is held and
defended by the the Defense Forces of
Ukraine additional Weaponry will help
them to keep on that defense line and
the Ukrainian forces have proven over
the past years that they are capable of
holding that line
I'm sure you're aware that Germany is
not sending weapons to Ukraine and one
reason that has been offered here in
Berlin is that weapons would be a drop
in the bucket they would make no
difference in the ability of Ukraine to
fight Russia's Mighty military I mean in
terms of numbers and strength is that a
valid argument would more weapons
actually do more harm than good in
Ukraine
I would argue that weapon delivery alone
will not address the complex situation
entirely more is needed and I would also
suggest that not all measures should be
excluded from right from the beginning
weapon delivery sanctions political
measures other support activities by the
West should remain on the table weapon
delicious alone standing as I mentioned
before won't really change the situation
as it is now more is needed and to the
delivery must also come dialogue must
come discussions on what possible
economic activities and sanctions could
be put in place should aggression
continue to be displayed let me put you
on the spot here Mr hook do you think
Germany is making a mistake by not
sending weapons to Ukraine
I think all options should remain on the
table options are there to generate a
reaction from the opposite side and that
reaction will then help to continue
finding a solution out of this stalemate
you know this week French president
Emmanuel macron he met with Russian
President Putin in following their
meeting macron said that the Minsk II
agreement which aimed at ending the war
in eastern Ukraine he said it's the only
path to peace now do you agree
the Minsk agreements not only contain
measures to stop the fighting that we
have just been discussing in eastern
Ukraine but also they contain measure on
the humanitarian economic and political
side to address this conflict that
package of measures as imperfect as it
might be is the only one that is
currently available and it is also also
the platform where discussions currently
do take place the dialogue on how to
implement these agreements will help to
find eventually a solution out of that
conflict but it requires everyone who
have signed these agreements to play
along well you know Russia still insists
that it is not a party to the conflict
in eastern Ukraine and is therefore not
bound by the terms of the Minsk
agreements I mean do you foresee any way
to change Vladimir Putin's mind
regarding that
the Normandy talks the Normandy four
talks include the Russian Federation the
Russian Federation has signed all the
agreements that have been signed and
means including that means two agreement
that has been signed on the 12th of
February 2014 Russia is part of of this
discussion and Russia must be part of
the solution
so Russia though by signing it and yet
saying it's still not a party to the
conflict is we're speaking out of both
sides of its mouth isn't it
Russia has obligations under these
agreements and these obligations
continue to apply and Russia also takes
this series it continues to contribute
to these debates Russia has a stake in
this conflict and Russia must be part of
the solution to this conflict in eastern
Ukraine but also the much broader
conflict that is brewing in Eastern
Europe you know tomorrow Mr who's here
in Berlin envoys from France Germany
Russia and Ukraine they will be meeting
I mean if you are an optimist what do
you see as the best possible outcome
I would hope for Less diplomacy with the
megaphone but more diplomacy Behind
Closed store so that the quite different
positions that Russia and the West now
have can be discussed behind closed
doors so that positions can't be
explained and solutions can be found
it's very important that Ukraine is part
of this discussion then it is all about
Ukraine and as long as Ukraine is in
these discussions I'm confident that
solutions that would support Ukraine's
sovereignty and integrity can be found
Mr Huge Before I Let You Go what is your
personal opinion about the Russian troop
build up along Ukraine's border do you
think Vladimir Putin will order an
invasion
I think the buildup of forces is part of
the negotiation tactic that the Russian
Federation has displayed I would not say
that I would exclude it but I also would
not say that it will happen tomorrow it
is part of a wider plan I assume that
Moscow has to engage in dialogue in
confrontation with the West to make its
position clear the dialogue that will
happen tomorrow in Berlin and all the
ones that we have seen in the past
couple of days and weeks are part now of
what will play out in response to that
build up Mr Alexander who gets very good
to get your insights tonight especially
someone who knows what's going on on the
ground in eastern Ukraine we appreciate
it very much thank you
thank you
for more now I'm joined by Raphael loss
he is with the European Council on
Foreign Relations Mr Lawson it's good to
see you again so what do we got going on
here NATO and Russian forces are holding
War Games as political leaders are doing
all types of diplomacy trying to find a
diplomatic breakthrough but they haven't
do you see these War Games as being some
type of strategic you know saber
rattling
well as your report just outlined Russia
has amassed upwards of a hundred
thousand troops on the border with
Ukraine and has deployed troops to
Belarus for exercises uh NATO reports
that that these are the largest
deployments to Belarus and since the end
of the Cold War
um the Russian Navy is amassing uh ships
and the Black Sea uh and the Russian
national guard is mobilizing units
um at the same time nato in an effort to
uh show support to to Eastland allies to
reassure them to signal to Russia that
there is a resolve to act United as an
alliance and to defend NATO territory at
the same time NATO gears have not in any
way indicated that they would send
troops to fight alongside Ukraine rather
to the contrary they've met very clear
that NATO would not be involved
let's compare the numbers though from Mr
laws you know you've got 130 000 Russian
troops along the border with Ukraine the
U.S sending what 2 000 troops to Eastern
Europe NATO members I mean that's that's
just a drop in the bucket it's more
symbolic than anything else right
really symbolic it raised really an
effort to to bolster
um NATO support for Eastern allies these
troops will not be involved in any
conflict between Russia or Ukraine
um but they are supposed to signal to
Russia that NATO is serious and that it
is serious about protecting its
territory and its allies
um as I said NATO leaders have in no way
indicated that they would get involved
and fight alongside Ukraine but they've
sent weapons they have uh outlaid uh
described a serious sanctions package
that would significantly hurt Russia if
there was a real Attack on Ukraine and
there's been other sort of economic
support for Ukraine as it is suffering a
severe economic crisis and that has been
triggered by this uh you know Specter of
of renewed War
tomorrow here in Berlin we're going to
have negotiators from the group that's
known as the Normandy format to France
Germany Ukraine and Russia they're going
to meet they're going to try to salvage
the Minsk to agreement which was
designed to bring peace to Eastern
Ukraine
what are your chances there for anything
coming out of this meeting other than a
lot of talk
I mean it is encouraging that we
continue to talk that Western leaders
have visited Vladimir Putin and the
Kremlin over the past couple of days the
German Chancellor is going to visit next
week and there's close coordination
between NATO allies between the European
Union member states with partners and in
the region including Ukraine and to get
the get the get everything on the
Diplomatic track towards the escalation
but in the end this is Putin's decision
to make whether um he wants to use any
of the off-ramps that NATO leaders have
presented him with and as proposal on
the table to engage in Risk reduction
measures and reduce stability talks to
renew and arms control agenda between
the west and Russia but as the true
buildup continues the the pressure and
the tensions continue when this could be
a very sort of drawn out crisis that we
see over the next couple of weeks
continue
ravia lost with the European Council on
Foreign Relations Mr laws as always we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
but the U.S is sending more than a
thousand troops from Germany to Romania
to beef up NATO's Eastern European
defenses Romania has been investing
heavily in defense as well as
modernizing its Armed Forces DW's
Alexander phenomen takes us on a naval
exercise in the Black Sea
a military drill on board a Romanian
warship the simulated scenario the
regional Ferdinand frigate has been hit
by a missile the crew's job is to save
lives and to put out the fire the ship
has just been through a maintenance
period the commanding officer Captain
Georgia Victor Dura tells me that it's
now crucial for the crew to get back in
shape for future operations including
joint NATO exercises
for us it is an opportunity to train
together to show that we are capable of
operating together and at the same time
to show Romanians that we're a security
provider in the Black Sea
Regional security
since becoming a NATO member Romania has
increased its defense spending to just
over two percent of the GDP investing in
the modernization of its forces an
investment deemed necessary given
security challenges in the region
since the illegal annexation of Crimea
in 2014 the Black Sea has become a
Flashpoint in tensions between Moscow
and the West Russia has significantly
increased its military presence and the
size of its Black Sea Fleet
headquartered its Sebastopol a port
that's less than 400 kilometers from
here
the sailors here say they are not afraid
of a Russian aggression still the
government has been calling on NATO to
boost its military presence in the
region
crimea's annexation was a real shock to
Romanians because it literally happened
on their doorstep since Armand Gosha a
Russia expert in Bucharest
if Russia fires a rocket from Crimea it
will arrive in Bucharest in 10 minutes
the biggest shock however was not only
the fact that Russia annexed Crimea but
the fact that the West did not respond
on the streets in Bucharest the mood
seems to favor hosting additional native
forces in the country it's a good thing
it can only have a positive influence
and we're safer
yes considering that we are
strategically positioned between the
East and the West we have the Black Sea
as well
I think it's a bad thing Romania is not
under threat under any circumstances
NATO has already stationed up to 4 000
troops in Romania 900 of them are U.S
service members with additional forces
on their way the Americans are doubling
the number of soldiers here but many
among Romania's political Elite would
like to see an even larger NATO
contingent in their country resembling
those already in place in the Baltic
states and Poland
says he believes strengthening NATO's
posture here would benefit all allies
there is a need to deter the Russian
enthusiasm in military terms and to
consolidate the Eastern flank of NATO
that means also a much stronger military
presence of the Allies on the Romanian
territory
on board the regional Ferdinand the crew
is gearing up for New Missions we don't
talk politics they say we're here to do
our job whatever it takes